[Music]
[Music]
what makes a movie truly sexy enough to
be included in our guide of the sexiest
movies ever variety is our spice for
some movies it's about the animal
chemistry between its stars or the
building passion of its characters with
others the turn on is the illicit thrill
of being bad or the purity of
self-awakening and discovery
[Music]
waving to the girls in the stands he's
kicking me to high heaven but they don't
catch for me
sometimes it's about the mood a movie
evokes intoxicating and overwhelming and
yeah sometimes it's about the sex scenes
whatever your definition though we are
counting down the best sexy movies all
ranked by tomato meter
[Music]
number 10 boogie nights
in the san fernando valley in 1977
teenage busboy eddie adams gets
discovered by porn director jack horner
who transforms him into adult film
sensation dirk diggler brought into a
supportive circle of friends including
fellow actors amber waves roller girl
and reed rothschild dirk fulfills all
his ambitions but a toxic combination of
drugs and egotism threatens to take him
back down starring mark wahlberg burt
reynolds julianne moore and directed by
paul thomas anderson critics say
grounded in strong characters bold
themes and subtle storytelling boogie
nights is a groundbreaking film both for
director pt anderson and star mark
wahlberg you sure you don't want to
fresco no thanks are you sure yeah
you're out of lines jack
well check in the kitchen darling
i'm going to bed
good night jackie
stay up too late
good night dude
good night eddie
glad you came by
you're great
thank you
she's the best
she's a wonderful mother you know
she's a mother to all those who need
love
she's really nice
you know what i'm thinking i'm thinking
i want to be in business with you ed
really
what do you think i'd love it
what do you think a roller girl
she's great yeah
would you like to do it
have sex oh yeah
yeah and i'd love to she's
she's really foxy no i bet you
you're officially out of lines jack well
i'll pick up some for you tomorrow's on
number nine carol
therese velvet spots the beautiful
elegant carol perusing the doll displays
in a 1950s manhattan department store
the two women develop a fast bond that
becomes a love with complicated
consequences starring cate blanchett
rooney mara sarah paulson and directed
by todd haynes critics say shaped by ton
haines's death direction and powered by
a strong cast led by cate blanchett and
rooney mara carol lives up to its
groundbreaking source material
played it for you on piano at your house
now remember
thank you oh god don't i look afraid you
do not you look wonderful
just stay like that
do you miss richard
no i haven't thought about him all day
number eight weekend
a gay man's weekend-long encounter with
an artist changes his life in unexpected
ways starring tom cullen chris knew
jonathan race and directed by andrew
haye critics say it may be a chamber
piece but weekend's revelations on
modern sexuality expand far beyond the
modest setting what are you writing
nothing well at least mug for example
this is probably owned by
some lovely little old lady with a
moustache
and
she bought it and it was her favorite
thing in the whole wide world and then
she died gave it to her grandchildren
they hated it
sold it
and then bought an xbox or a wee or some
flat pack wardrobe from
ikea know i've got it
i like that
it's very costly mug
to be able to buy a wii
i don't even know how much those things
are
all right do you want uh milk sugar
yeah one or both
okay
let's go wait for the cattle
you hungry
i've got some nice better beds
okay
well i'm starving so i'm gonna have to
eat
number seven the handmaiden with help
from an orphan pickpocket a korean con
man devises an elaborate plan to seduce
and build a japanese woman out of her
inheritance starring kim min-hee kim
tae-ree ha-jung-woo and directed by park
chun wuk critics say the handmaiden uses
a victorian crime novel as the loose
inspiration for another visually
sumptuous and absorbingly idiosyncratic
outing from director park chan woke up
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
number six sex lies and videotape anna's
trapped in a sexually and emotionally
unfulfilled relationship with her
husband john a successful but unpleasant
lawyer who's sleeping with her sister
cynthia the underlying tensions in the
couple's marriage rise to the surface
when graham a friend of john's from
college who's been drifting for nine
years returns to town and videotapes
cynthia and anne as they talk about
their sexual desires starring james
spader andy mcdowell peter gallagher and
directed by steven soderbergh critics
say in his feature directorial debut
stephen soderbergh's sex lies in
videotape demonstrates a mastery of his
craft well beyond his ears pulling
together an outstanding cast and an
intelligent script for a nuanced mature
film about neurosis and human sexuality
so where's he from
i don't know
yeah i used to live in new york and
philadelphia
i think he just kind of travels around
must be nice
so what's he like does he like john no
i don't think john likes him anymore
he says he thinks he's gotten kind of
strange
is he
strange i mean
no
i mean if i saw him on the street i
might think so
after meeting and talking to him i just
say he's kind of unusual
so what's he look like
why
i just want to know what he looks like
is that all right so you can go after
him jesus and get a life i just asked
what he looked like
what business is that of yours why do
you have to say that
say what you know what you say it just
irritate me
i say it because it's descriptive
well he doesn't strive as the kind of
person who's going for that kind of
thing anyway
and you always underestimate me i wonder
why
number five my beautiful launderette
in a seedy corner of london omar a young
pakistani is given a rundown laundromat
by his uncle who hopes to turn it into a
successful business soon after omar is
attacked by a group of racist punks but
defuses the situation when he realizes
that their leader is his former lover
johnny the men resume their relationship
and rehabilitate the laundromat together
but various social forces threaten to
compromise their success starring daniel
day lewis gordon warnecki saeed jaffrey
and directed by steven frears critics
say my beautiful laundrette is fast and
all over the place because it has so
much to say in show including a highly
watchable fresh-faced daniel day-lewis
why don't people like laundrettes
because they're like toilets
this could be a ritz among laundrettes
a long direct as big as the rates
oh yes
oh
leave it out
why are you working for these people
it's work that's why
i want to do some work for a change
instead of always hanging around what
you're jealous no i'm angry johnny
i don't like to see one of our blokes
groveling to
but they came over here to work for us
that's why we brought them over okay
number four body heat scheister lawyer
ned racine begins a passionate affair
with maddie walker wife of a wealthy
florida businessman with the help of one
of his criminal clients bomb maker teddy
lewis ned hatch is a scheme to kill
matty's husband so that they can run
away together with his money but
complications build upon double crosses
launching the hapless lawyer into a
situation far more treacherous than he
imagined starring william hurt kathleen
turner mickey rourke and directed by
lawrence kazdan critics say made from
classic noir ingredients and flavored
with a heaping helping of steamy modern
spice body heat more than lives up to
its evocative title
[Music]
you can stand here with me if you want
but you'll have to agree not to talk
about the heat
i'm a married woman
meaning what
meaning i'm not looking for company and
you should have said i'm a happily
married woman that's my business
what
how happy i am and how happy is that
you're not too smart are you
i like that in a man what else do you
like lazy ugly horny i got them all you
don't look lazy
[Music]
tell me does chat like this work with
most women
some if they haven't been around much i
wondered i thought maybe i was out of
touch i might buy you a drink i told you
i've got a husband
i'll buy him one too he's out of town
my favorite kind we'll drink to it
only comes up on weekends
i'm liking him better all the time
number three portrait of a lady on fire
in 1770 the young daughter of a french
countess develops a mutual attraction to
the female artist who's commissioned to
paint her wedding portrait starring
noemi milan adele hanel luanna bajrami
and directed by celine ciama critics say
a singularly rich period piece portrait
of a lady on fire finds stirring
thought-provoking drama within a
powerfully acted romance
alrighty
girl
so he says
look
[Music]
[Applause]
number two moonlight
a look at three defining chapters in the
life of chiron a young black man growing
up in miami his epic journey to manhood
is guided by the kindness support and
love of the community that helps raise
him starring mahershala ali alex r
hibbert janelle monae and directed by
barry jenkins critics say moonlight uses
one man's story to offer a remarkable
and brilliantly crafted look at lives
too rarely seen in cinema huh
what happened tyrone why you didn't come
home like you're supposed to
huh
and who is you
nobody
i found him yesterday
found him in a hole on 15.
yeah that one
some boys chased him in the cut he's
scared more than anything
he wouldn't tell me where he lived here
this morning
well thanks for saying to him he usually
can take care of himself
be good that way but
no man
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
titanic
james cameron's titanic is an epic
action-packed romance set against the
ill-fated maiden voyage of the rms
titanic the pride and joy of the white
star line and at the time the largest
moving object ever built she was the
most luxurious liner of her era the ship
of dreams which ultimately carried over
a thousand five hundred people to their
death in the ice cold waters of the
north atlantic in the early hours of
april 15 1912 starring leonardo dicaprio
kate winslet kathy bates and directed by
james cameron critics say titanic is a
mostly unqualified triumph for james
cameron who offers a dizzying blend of
spectacular visuals and old-fashioned
melodrama
come on
come on give me your hand
you don't want to do this
i have to get you to write that one down
come on
[Music]
now pull yourself up come on
[Applause]
that's right
[Applause]
[Applause]
bound sparks fly when violet sets eyes
on corki in an elevator violet is a
girlfriend of a violent gangster caesar
while corki is fresh out of prison and
doing renovations on the apartment next
door as the two women launch into a
passionate love affair they assemble an
intricate plan for violet to escape from
caesar with two million dollars of the
mob's money but the important part is to
make it out alive starring jennifer
tilly gina gershon joe pantagliano and
directed by lily and lana wachowski
critics say bound's more titillating
elements attracted attention but it's
the stylish direction solid performances
and entertaining neo-noir caper plot
that make it worth a watch beautiful
elaborate
are you surprised to know what it is
maybe
[Music]
i have a tattoo
would you like to see it
a woman in upstate new york did it for
me
do you like it
took her all day to do it
she promised it wouldn't hurt but
it was sore for a long time after
brokeback mountain in 1963 rodeo cowboy
jack twist and ranch han enis delmar are
hired by rancher joe aguirre as sheep
herders in wyoming one night on
brokeback mountain jack makes a drunken
pass to anus that is eventually
reciprocated though enis marries his
longtime sweetheart alma and jack marry
is a fellow rodeo rider the two men keep
up their tortured and sporadic affair
over the course of 20 years starring
heath ledger jake gyllenhaal linda
cardellini and directed by ang lee
critics say a beautiful epic western
brookback mountain's love story is
imbued with heartbreaking universality
thanks to moving performances by heath
ledger and jake gyllenhaal you are too
much for me yes
you selling a horse
i wish i knew how to quit you
why don't you
why don't you just let me be huh
because you jack that i'm like this
nothing
i'm nowhere
oh sorry
all right
and finally number one gloria
an aging divorcee embarks on an intense
affair with a man she picked up at a
disco starring paulina garcia sergio
hernandez diego fontesilla and directed
by sebastian lillia critics say
marvelously directed by sebastian leo
and beautifully led by a powerful
performance from paulina garcia gloria
takes an honest sweetly poignant look at
a type of character that is all too
often neglected in hollywood
foreign
foreign
[Laughter]
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the ron
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love and until
next time i am your host naz perez and
we'll see you back here for more top 10s
on the rotten tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you